Randy Dahn is a research scientist at the Mount Desert Island Biological Laboratory,...
...a biomedical research facility near Bar Harbor, Maine.
Dahn and his colleagues are studying skates and other marine vertebrates...
...to find out how they regrow their fins.
So, they carefully amputate their fins,...
...and then, study the role genes play in regenerating them.
So once we understand, we can compare and contrast how all these different groups accomplish this feat,...
...and then, we can then apply that knowledge to higher vertebrates like humans and mice.
Salamanders also regrow their limbs.
Scientists have been studying how they regenerate their limbs for decades...
...and they understand how tissues interact with each other during this process,...
...but the real challenge is to understand what's happening at the molecular level.
So right now, we're trying to figure out what genes drive this process...
...and then, once we understand that, we can understand why humans fail to regenerate their limbs,...
...and then hopefully, through genetic trickery, restore that ability.